want you call it look noir edmond olek
military arsenault
[Musique]
designed to save lives peut-être coup de
pied pour l'un des deux sites par
formation pour garder le chemin
pacifique
la réponse naturelle c'est le répondre
avec la violence
c'est pas une méthode de contrôle de
foule de terry sur le monde
6 yeuse aftenposten no 15 chefs de
fraude light en event
c'est pas le franc se faire insulter
mais ces symboles qui attaque c'est pas
le point ici c'était pas capable de
comprendre cet appât d'affaires lauvaux
classé des beaux quartiers mike
[Musique]
francis grenier avec spirit marc grenier
de groupe peuvent tout voir la dame
d'une prestation c'est très festif
j'avais apporté en arménie club de
protest against the building
hamon
de protester bolivie week end festif à
dubaï
on a vu que bon ça va bosser on la
regarde la télévision
après ça on a vu les fameuses bon et
c'est joli exploit
le manga une première salve on a couru
et pour s'éloigner de quad obèses
deuxième salve au lieu et c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai été blessé
j'ai toujours mon visage j'ai regardé ma
main je voyais ça sur ma main
c'est quoi ça
j'avais aucune dit qu'est ce qui se
passe au niveau de même si on savait que
je voyais pas mon endroit française
grenier à droite bloque pas nn la presse
a du talent beaucoup de travail et est
beaucoup plus blessé que facebook n'est
fait alain arsenault et francis grannies
la lse solide hôpital pierre deux
policiers qui arrivent et qui est ceci
qu'est ce qui est si ça plaît le père de
francis grenier du personnel et fermi
ils n'ont même cachet des policiers
pourquoi que pour que les policiers
cesse de la harceler leur ai demandé
s'ils avaient une plainte et apporter
non non non mais c'est parce que pour
notre enquête policière formée
requesting jackman n'ont pas le droit
c'est des personnes en exercice de la
fonction qui vont n'ont pas enquêté sur
écrire la quête poisson est clair il
veut juste savoir que ce qui a eu pour
se trouver un système de défense de
police ou des ventes chez les klein date
française grenoble angels paris piece of
ice hockey moderne scripps
bush au stade de grenade et de munitions
des femmes n'avaient pas du tout ils ont
plaidé préfet comme si de rien n'était
c'est seulement compte interrogatoire
qu'on a réussi à obtenir des
informations qu'on croit qu'il va
changer de politique sans les crises des
polices voie ouverte à recommander on a
un débriefing il n'y a rien d'écrit le
tee shirt un carré mais je vais vous
êtes au projet parce que est un
organisme public à cause d'un doigt de
l'accès à l'information les informations
quand il faut qu'ils soient transmises
alors on fait un débriefing on se parle
des vraies choses mais y'a pas toujours
des notes depuis parce que le système
étant comme il y est il ya des choses
qu'on veut poterie soir alors ça doit
être plus transparent ce que je vous ai
assez de lait ou au cache des choses au
public aux médias et on essaye un
médecin de camoufler sa responsabilité
civile générale de stratégie de lancer
des grenades assourdissantes
tous deux ont dit que ces pauvres 2
orienter la foule puis elle assure 30
pts sur le dernier chose que tu feras
contrôle de foule m'a semblé désorienté
afful police on envoie le dd
et sans athènes de documents vidéo le
sur yahoo double les policiers qui sont
déplaisants son insulte les gens
il fait tout ce qui bouge pour
compliquer le tout ce qui bouge de forme
police a fait sur les conseils de marc
machin qui domine en tout cas dans sexus
du monde qu'est ce qui fait de lui
chercher ce soit notre lexus dans le
doubs manger la pointe d'un bâton alors
quand tu frappes parle dans la colonne
vertébrale se fait briser les vertèbres
restée paralysée
reste aux policiers la nuit avec parler
quelqu'un qu'il donnait à sa fin ou qui
a montré que c'est comme ça que ça
marchait c'est un rouleau mais les deux
sont inacceptables est exagérée qui
pointe une police coach de nice teaching
femmes département a partagé sa dette et
d'une philosophie on reconnaît
aujourd'hui à manifester la discipline
professionnalisme la retenue
l'empathie tout des éléments qui font du
bac de messages constamment
bottes de grenier unité police fo estimé
philippe pichet de fioul chiffres de
metropolis libre la mise en garde de
céréales s'est équilibré ça peut tuer ça
déjà depuis 2003 coeur le droit de
manifester quand même un droit
fondamental il compterait pour l'exercer
en toute sécurité
des stands de ces jeunes et jolis
clichés einstein ce match que nous ok on
va payer échec
ça va faire 1 204 me pierre magnol
aucune remise en question des façons de
fin des gestes posés par qui que ce soit
si je me fais ce que moi j'entends c'est
en cours ça va peut être un chien ou un
short ça pour faire rapport était plus
grave c'est à des dommages collatéraux
montreuil police refuse française
grenier numérique avec remise angie be
lost my dreams is good for ever c'est
plus difficile
le magazine avec ces restrictions et
j'ai aussi le sentiment d'être plus rien
puis à ce que je sache la 7 mars au 20
heures été causés par les forces de
l'ordre
francis grenoble ou mena biden effectué
à deux jeunes de following its and
police libyenne pour fuir des violences
extrêmes particulièrement victoriaville
qui était pour moi un piège
extraordinaire on a abouti à une
escalade dû entre autres au manque de
professionnels des policiers et au
manque de contrôle de police y aurait
deux victoires et proteste never before
six vidéos n à 8 noeuds 5 ans chez nous
là on danse trad g20
inde est normal
pensionnaire au québec province police
de sûreté du québec
mais ni immédiat take engine de
victoriaville démonstration
i would be replaced by the politics
committee for life
rappelons-nous tirs avec des finances
peut-être les pales dans ces
circonstances que je me dis que c'est un
danger public
c'est de toute façon de et public joe
and wood and the seven i found that
should plastique bulls de speed be used
against one présence service traite si
je l'atteins sur une jambe c'est certain
que
amoureux pas personne ne la voyais faire
mal à votre avis mais si je l'atteins la
gorge ou latin un peu importe à
t'attendre n'importe koué de c'est ce
que le chef de l'état d' in
victoriaville liste états unis des
monstres et russe un seul corps le
congrès du parti libéral avait été jugé
par les membres de la coalition à
l'assemblée comme un moment à 16 heures
pour aller exprimer notre opposition non
seulement la hausse des frais de
scolarité mais aux autres mesures
d'austérité tâter de police bloquent des
routes nombreux one nos contacts aussi
stable est organisé vingt personnes qui
est le contact de des services de police
et est-ce qu'on lui a répondu à ce
moment là c'est si on a besoin de vous
parler on va vous trouver de se faire
renvoyer pas être comme ça je pense que
c'était jamais arrivé dans une
manifestation de de la coalition in de
police log des notes de président sont
des monstres et des restes de black
blocks alexandre allard et you don't
want to miss g trouve aussi un parapluie
chapeau dont l effigie du québec que
j'ai mis ce matin que j'ai eus durant
les deux manifestations distinctes ou de
sécuri dix ans et ce pauvre les
protecteurs les fameuses quatre retenus
avec des attaches en plastique ne peut
pas laisser série d'étapes c'est très
bien il manifestants ont commencé seul
le mas de fès goes down
[Applaudissements]
3 encore dean
l'esma regroupe des monstres une espèce
de sports extrêmes pour certaines
personnes d'aller dans des manifs puis
s'attaquer aux policiers pour tous au il
ya quand même faut pas perdre de vue que
on parle d'une poignée d'individus mme
morayef police encore d une claudine
fait sur des niveaux rouge allure elle
abat les les événements victoriaville là
car remonter la dernière fois que vous
aviez tiré une vingtaine d'impacts et je
suis un pur jeu n'est pas est-ce que
c'est ça pouvait remonter à votre
qualification proposing 6-2
[Musique]
mystique number three de maastricht et
cela est une de jane austen fusion c'est
le chaos
on sentait qu au niveau sonore même
s'ils font des appels avec un mois ce
haut parleur
c'est pas tout le monde qui veut
l'entendre on a vingt camions tous
avaient un bon système de sonorisation
donc c'est sûr que si on avait une
information leur est transmis aux mots
stade de saint omer caso fayyad inch
haut du crâne
les gens sont choqués
de scandaliser de paiement la police
avait rapidement les garder comme a
finalement la manifestation n'avait pas
pu se tenir
magali paquet mode i love to oiseaux
pietri tout dit il ya peu de gradation
en fait c'est très rapidement on est
passé d'une manifestation tout à fait
conventionnelle bon enfant à une
déploiement c'est intense puis agressif
les personnes qui comprenait ce qui se
passait les parents avec leurs enfants
en poussette se sauvaient parce que ils
savaient pas où aller puis quoi faire
les enfants pleuraient comme soit 9
je peux aussi surpris jean pierre roy et
louis de groupe aux meneurs the games to
machine cuisse du groupe
il n'a rien d'un monstre et si vous ne
les appelle veut pas si bien
pour y parvenir et auprès de gens qui
étaient équipées incommodés par des gaz
puis ont été portées par notre union et
elle même n'étaient pas nouvelles mais
commandé
dams three days grace park des rôles
longue red bend between them and
politics fifty-five pml et les pierres
des morceaux tabligh des balles pour les
morceaux de bois y en a tellement dans
mes souvenirs à moins de 7 et constant
s'arrêter pour faire un tel procès
telles que la galerie nous bombardait
partout les gens tentent le ton sont en
danger que tu te dois te défendre puis
comme je dis ô dieu quand c'est tout le
monde au moins 30 départ était capable
de faire des bonnes personnes
denis burel de ce nom efi kort de rivers
dans le feu de l'action le il est allé
ou après sur le bateau cinétique
non seulement vous ayez un bâton
cinétique c'est quand même assez rigide
ça peut avoir un impact très dommage
hein vous d'accord avec moi je peux
viser la même chose des morceaux de
payer ou d'une bande de pauvres bout de
temps avec moi que c'est vous le
professeur lapidot rendez vous les
manifestants
c'est moi qui ai policiers ou les jeux
donc vous êtes formés pour savoir tirer
et pour savoir où vous tirez avec moi
mais là la bonne chose qui se passe en
avant ne sais pas jason perfectionnons
plus une fente en fait subir l iran est
ce que vous est il vraiment parfait je
la tenais c'est vrai que c'est rien mais
finalement on devrait sacrer une comme
protection imaginaire contre les
policiers devant nous
useless demande de nouvelles files
alexandra l'appel catastrophique
il appelle connu c'est quelqu'un
inconscient il y avait une respiration
rapide qui nous questionner sur quel
type de traumatisme et le pur saubot
respiration la paix traumatismes à la
tête sa voie publique
est ce que c'est possible que vous ayez
atteint la personne commises au sein
d'aig et vous montrer le
pas où j'ai donné but réel shop boys
[Musique]
alexandre allard spinning heures le
comité exprime sa loge est le mec j'ai
pas eu tant de la poser la question un
jeudi le sa part été le seul moment
donné vous de ce qui se passe que je
tremble ces problèmes ce qui la situe
moi je leur ai exposé pour éliminer un
manifestant qui sans me lancer quelque
chose
moi je pense que c'est un cerveau pas de
jeu ça vaut pas le jeu parce que tu me
pose quand même de ses 19 ans
les politiques ont serré quelques
blessés dominique la liberté martine
aubry si le projecteur in deux fils et
kinetics tic est en baisse de 20,6 du
free jazz y est restée moi j'ai je me
s'éloigner parce qu'elle avait
évidemment beaucoup de gaz lacrymogène
et je suis allé à contre 20 pour me
mettre à l'abri mais chic ce moment
facebook tous ses effectifs européens
des projecteurs et l'oeil un monsieur en
fait qui approche et qui me tend un
objet vert s'est avéré être un bâton
cinétique
il me dit c'est ça qui vous a frappé
madame je l' ai vu c'est ce qui vous a
frappé si vous d'avoir tiré à 20 kg 10
go vas-y j'ai pensé démissionner mais je
me suis un peu si un danger pour la vie
ou la vie dans mes confrères petit démon
armes à feu pour moi le jeu par un guy
lacombe me taper je n'ai pas pu me dire
mais là lily rush comment cette
dangereuse autorisation m'inspire last
resort beaucoup beaucoup d'adrénaline de
stress là dedans la peur la colère
c'est un cocktail explosif quand ménage
tous ensemble celui qui est en arrière
lui faut que je sois au courant de ce
soit conscient de ce bac s de squad
commanders denis burelle a des
obligations
richard pas mal plus occupé la fillette
protéger les membres de mon peloton fois
supérieur
[Musique]
protestors trail twitter de pauli 3 0 de
l'iphone alexandre allard et ndjoli
facture du corps dont beaucoup cachaient
inédite où les évacuer de 2012
[Applaudissements]
obligés de déplacer à nouveau à l'écran
on l'avait pressé trop fois pour moi
alors que c'est un constat d'un point de
vue de soigner de déplacer ce type de
possibles violences lisent pas de
questions on peut suggérer des réponses
est ce que c'est à dire noir est ce
qu'elle était qu'est ce que vous faisiez
est-ce que vous lancer des projectiles
c'était un peu tendancieux j'étais pas
capable de la lune parce que sauf accord
de ma condition donc ils ont lu pour moi
qui ai je pense que c'est moi qui ai
signé quand même je comprenais pas là
l'importance que ces documents alors que
ses déclarations
gibbs c'est vraiment frustrant de voir
les policiers qui ne va pas c'est comme
si c'était moi en fait qui était avec
trou causé ma situation
comme si dès le départ aucune chance à
steve lee jones a fait subir aux actions
de blocage et je peux pas le profil de
sûreté du québec
les internationaux team of d'anthrax
inouïe de l'opposition que si on utilise
ses armes
on peut éviter les blessures graves ou
les mots et en fait c'est pas vrai le
best way police khan younis d'iron 16
docteur wendel expérience chose quand
ces armes même avec les manifestants qui
sont pas pacifique
on voit qu'ils sont souvent utilisés
dans une maria qui qui dirige toutes les
manifestations dans une direction d'une
sens un pire et les faits tout à fait
que les gens qui sont placés les gens
qui meurent sont souvent des gens qui
étaient en train de manifester
pacifiquement le live show inquiry yann
de victoriaville
enjoy and policies and responsibility
type xss parce que on les appelle samy
létale moins mortel il nécessite pas le
type de formation de régleur de revues
après les incidents pour voir comment
servir utiliser césar
[Musique]
conrad hervé fort lors des 25
victoriaville from hydromine de
charlevoix ruijin de retard sur 20 et
porte à fait conscient et sonne mathieu
aux moudjahidine place que les
politiques focus sur la défense du
territoire et repos chiche troyens et
laisse porter des jeans obligé show chab
mais ne réfléchis sa 21e 0 et 20 de
femmes les exceptions total d'heures
store
le fbi américain
tu t'attendais du québec a dit mathieu
harvey a just 6 manuelle
[Musique]
hautement plus manifestants la police
essayait d'empêcher de monter et pro
twin et first season one green bean
curiace tout frêne ouasti 25 fautes
femmes de ta bave série instruite
l'événement comme d'envergure qui se
passait dans ma vie où je voulais être
là pour voir ce qui se passe comme une
scène de guerre
le feu
les policiers l'abri de washington
le trottoir que la police a tourné le
coin vers nous on est toutes passées à
courir va derrière moi et lui il y
aurait des goûters et il fait bien jouer
aux côtés de presse que nous a raconté
piocher sur lui de chan chan l'ingénieur
foulard puis clopes il le peut il ne pas
abandonner
3 mark fast enough
les débris d'un côté donc il fallu que
je descende la cote à ce moment là cités
de deux personnes pour me rendre jusqu'à
l'ambulance moment selon le rapport
environ 2 8 crd effets quantiques qui
mixe this way down ninety nine steps to
the world of gaming les veines partie de
mon crâne à peu près gros comme ce qui
était complètement broyé puis le dure
mère qui la petite pas autour du cerveau
avait été déchiré les fragments d'os ont
atteint le cerveau mais on peut pénétrer
son déposer dessus
donc j'avais testé ouvert la voie il ya
marcher sur un fil pour venir d'être
quelqu'un qui qui je fais quelle partie
de l'ossature du cerveau qui parti et
que la tour mongoumba ciocarlie à
travers la peau qui reste au tour de
thomas frieden par là se cache tahiri
puis j'avais justement mon trou ici
maintenant la prison la face au tgs pour
la femme testait
dix femmes les reportings identité de
sûreté du québec few months later la
première ronde que j'ai eu avec un
policier se faisait l'événement j'avais
pas l'intention je n'avais pas
l'impression qu'ils qui étaient là pour
trouver le fin fond de l'histoire
j'étais plus on a l'impression qu'ils
essayaient de s'assurer que la police
soit pas mise en cause le sûreté
cliquant tout j'étais mort mais je
passais effectifs de prévoir et ils ont
formé le doji conrad harvey après tant
d'années on n'oublie pas on n'avait pas
pris beaucoup de débauche au sommet des
amériques pour qui l'arrivée j'ai
vainement de victor les rues et je vois
pas comme un policier expérimenté puis
est ce qu on maudit ceux qui naissent et
anglaise et du monde frère comme il peut
arriver à la conclusion qu'il faut que
ça grâce à cette méthode de 150
personnes du gauche on le met dans les
mains quelque chose on luigi d'avoir un
certain comportement mais ça dérape
le premier se remet à nos policiers
cette porte assistance aux citoyens
donc je sais pas comment des dizaines de
policiers formés entraînés payer pour ce
ont pu passer à côté de moi ce sont les
deux robots action on ne peut plus parce
que le des lettres chirurgien au moment
où on ne rejoue la vie comme de quoi ils
étaient ils étaient victimes de la
criminelle j'ai pas évident l2 des
fonctionnaires de décider des victimes
de la criminelle
quand possiblement le coupable c'est
l'appareil gouvernemental
et ils ont dit qu'ils étaient aux soins
intensifs à l'hôpital de trois-rivières
ma imaginez juste une seconde de
résultats de jobs pourquoi même prévoir
d'utiliser des armes qui pourraient
causer des blessures je pense qu'à la
barre on devrait se poser question long
since de victoriaville evans alexandre
allard les huit points bénite physical
security sur est dominique la liberté
martineau des bolt sur 200 m c'est une
entrave quoi je pense qu est le policier
qui aurait agi de cette manière là
individuellement un mal agi mais je
pense que c'est plus grand que je pense
que c'est vraiment dans la culture
policière
oui il ya une question de culture
première des choses on peut pas faire
d'erreur peuvent pas admettre qu est ce
qu on leur enseigne et peut-être pas
tout à fait corée devrait peut-être mode
s'y associer c'est possible de rhinau
dab dab police
robert gates a dit sabine meeting next
gen charlevoix tnp
[Musique]
à fribourg elle où elle était restée
digne du sinaï avait protesté daniel
gauvreau selon les informations que nous
avons obtenues
c'est que ce policier là aurait
justement était en train d'aider un
autre citoyen citoyens las des affiches
veuille ou non les dix officiers involve
inherent in situ et most hid pnd
démonstration de zidane
[Applaudissements]
notez véhicules sur vos poèmes et ouest
la foule pas où je ne dis pas en plus il
atterrit aux couleurs la sûreté brigode
sargent daniel gauvreau de side to enjoy
des protections prévues chaque à talence
la vache sur l'autobus il m'a vu bien la
mairie tomber la roche n'est pas trois
courses on touche porté à consacrer des
faits sont graves de cette fête des
mamans sont approchés rapidement
[Musique]
infiniti vient de terrain patrick côté
de pick up trucks drive in choi et qu'un
pick up saw 2 août
c'est qui ce fait je ne bouge pas comme
si on pensait on est pro box - van dam
[Applaudissements]
j'ai encore le chant dans la tête tu
vois tu pas peur d'aller sur les canaux
conseil tenaille
mais quand je vois la porte pour aller
ramasser daniel et j'ai une roche qui me
rappelle le derrière de la taille puis à
ce moment là ben y'a pas mon affaire ce
côté est noir de choice but to ninja
range dans la foule en espérant sortir
de l'eau sans croiser personne parce
qu'on km de voirie sont en alu c'était
l'outil utilisé d'armes à feu ce gouffre
au stand du positif de ce qui vous y
venez y compris des chefs d incentive
[Musique]
students ch din de phase i lost and
events la station charles de gaulle
c'est beau le sport après manifester tu
veux pas le lâcher mais là tu peux être
notion ton environnement tout ce que tu
puisses sur le focus manifestants à la
première chose que tu peux été menée en
cirque litres on envoie 4 5 autour de
toi te doublent gauvreau vacances
face à lui le fait que l'utilisation de
l'épaule puis que l'on envoyait ces gens
là qui n'en fait des roches qui nous
était mon travail tant qu'à moi de les
arrêter
c'était la mort éditions pika son
manteau
maxence sarah bernhardt swing de sûreté
du québec de 3 estime tout comme